i'd like to address straight away the
following question
why do we need to raise taxes
three reasons
first we need to properly fund the nhs
as we recover from the pandemic
senior nhs leaders have made clear that
without more funding
we will not properly be able to address
this significant backlog
in people's cancelled operations delayed
treatments or missed diagnoses
to get everyone the care they need is
going to take time
and it is going to take money
the second reason
is that the social care plans announced
today have created an expanded safety
net
instead of individuals having to bear
the financial risks of catastrophic care
costs themselves
we as a country
are deciding to share more of that risk
collectively
this is a permanent new role for the
government
and as such we need a permanent new way
to fund it
the only alternative
would be to borrow more indefinitely
but that would be irresponsible at a
time when our national debt is already
the highest it has been in peacetime
and it would be dishonest
borrowing more today just means higher
taxes tomorrow
the third reason we need to raise taxes
is to fund the government's vision
for the future of health and social care
properly funded
we can tackle not just the nhs backlog
and expand the social care safety net
we can afford the nurse's pay rise
invest in the newest most modern
equipment prepare for the next pandemic
and provide one of the largest
investments ever to upskill social care
workers
in other words
we can build the modern
more efficient health and social care
services the british public deserves
to fund this vital spending we will
introduce a new uk
health and social care levy
from next april we will ask businesses
employees and the self-employed to pay
an extra 1.25
on earnings
all the money we raise will be legally
ring fenced
which means every pound from the levy
will go directly to health and social
care
the levy is the best way to raise the
funds we need
it is fair the more you earn the more
you pay
it is honest
it is not a stealth tax or borrowed
the levy will be there in black and
white on people's payslips
and it is uk wide so people in england
scotland and wales and northern ireland
will all pay the same amount
to make sure everyone pays their fair
share we will also increase dividend tax
rates by the same amount
and from 2023 people over the age of 66
will be asked to pay the levy on their
earnings too
no government wants to have to raise
taxes
but these are extraordinary times and we
face extraordinary circumstances
for more than 70 years it has been an
article of faith in this country that
our national health service should be
free at the point of use funded by
general taxation
if we are serious
about defending this principle in a
post-covered world
we have to be honest with ourselves
about the cost that brings
and be prepared to take the difficult
and responsible decisions to meet them